dominique philias ancien responsable
syndical de sud aérien
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france et ce qu'on y voie
clair dont toutes les mesures prises par
le gouvernement
pas du tout le problème c'est que ce
sont des finances qui viennent d'où
parce que ces aides financières d'accord
mais elles viennent d'où l'aéroport
entre autres et pas forcément une
entreprise qui a besoin d'être
financière je pense qu'il ya d'autres
domaines qui sont beaucoup plus en
souffrance financièrement je ne dis pas
que les salariés de petits moyens
revenus n'ont pas besoin des d'aéroports
de paris
il y à une partie du personnel qui a
besoin d'être financières mais pas toute
l'entreprise et je crois que la
problématique aussi c'est que
l'entreprise a fait beaucoup de dépenses
ces derniers temps dans des
investissements pas forcément justifiée
dans tous les cas qu'il n'était moins vu
la réduction d'activité et que c'est de
l'argent qui a été dépensé et qui aurait
pu être utilisé autrement notamment pour
compenser l'activité diminué dans le
milieu du transport concernant cette
baisse progressive des indemnités qu'est
ce que ça signifie concrètement à la
fois pour les salariés et pour les chefs
d'entreprise alors justement c'est la
problématique est ce que le chef
d'entreprise a toute latitude pour
redistribuer entre guillemets cette aide
à sa manière par exemple dans une
entreprise on peut déplacer des salariés
d'une activité à une autre ça s'est fait
à aéroports de paris
s'il ya des salariés avec des activités
réduites qui ont été déplacés dans
d'autres services ou d'autres domaines
où l'activité n'est pas réduite et donc
ça a permis de ne pas les mettre au
chômage ou de réduire leurs dividendes
pour certains par exemple mettre des
salariés à la fondation de l'entreprise
je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
nécessité donc
de ce côté là tout dépend comment va
être utilisé l'aide financière et qui
valent à distribuer pour que ce soit
utile et bien utilisé abonnés ces eaux
le conseil des ministres s'est félicité
hier de l'efficacité de l'activité
partielle dans la prévention des
licenciements économiques ce sont les
termes c'est une véritable réussite
effectivement selon vous alors je pense
que c'est une couverture qui cache la
misère
aéroports de paris d'ailleurs à essayer
de mettre en place trois projets avec
une forme un peu de chantage en disant
que l'un n'allait pas sans l'autre et
ces projets avaient pour intention de
réduire les effectifs
l effectif global de l'entreprise et
certains avantages
ces projets ont été retoqués par les
représentations syndicales de
l'entreprise donc en fait un seul projet
a été mise en place et va l'être
c'est un problème de départ de rupture
conventionnelle collective donc qui va
permettre personnes âgées de quitter
l'entreprise pour celles qui le
souhaitent
c'est environ 1150 salariés dont à peu
près 700 ne seraient pas remplacés
donc ça n'a pas empêché ça n'empêchera
pas un employeur d'une manière ou d'une
autre de réduire les effectifs et les
avantages s'il le veut ça a été le cas
en tous les cas et on parle de paris
alors malgré un rebond de l'économie le
fc eux prévoient une forte hausse du
chômage en 2021 ce que ce n'est pas le
signe qu'il faut au contraire prolonger
le chômage partiel
oui on prolonge le chômage partiel sans
savoir en fait où on va
si les mesures sont rationnels par
exemple en ce qui concerne le sanitaire
bien sûr que le tourisme et le voyage ne
va pas remarcher comme ça devrait
marcher il faudrait qu'il y ait des
mesures nationales et qui des mesures
européennes pour qui comment dirais-je
une certaine logique sur l'avenir on
sait très bien aussi que le tourisme ne
remplit certaines activités ne
repartiront que quand la clientèle sera
rassuré on se dit que le vaccin sera une
manière de rassurer la clientèle
donc on est quand même dans un avenir
extrêmement floues l'état dépense
énormément d'argent dans tous les cas on
sait pas d'où ça vient
mais à un moment donné il va peut-être
falloir payer la facture
et là on va peut-être avoir certaines
réalités ou certaines vérités qui vont
apparaître
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation dominique ancien responsable
syndical de sud aérien